we begin with a pretty dangerous
situation for millions of Americans
before the holiday weekend there is a
historic winter storm that is Raging
across several States as we speak people
are urged to use Extreme Caution when
getting around on icy roads and in white
out conditions along with the snow wind
it is also bitterly cold in much of the
country and thousands have lost power
making conditions even worse we've got
team coverage throughout the region this
morning we're going to begin with Elise
Preston who is outside of Chicago she
will show us the impact this massive
storm is having
blustering winds
blinding snow
and blistering cold from the Midwest to
the South temperatures in 24 hours have
plunged more than 50 degrees and way
below zero like in Western Montana where
temperatures drop to minus 17 degrees
cold enough to make this boiling hot
water turn into a snow cloud in seconds
but for millions in the path of the
arctic-like conditions there's a real
danger with power outages expected and
the country's roads being blanketed with
ice even in the areas that have been
plowed really well if you get above 40
miles an hour you start sliding around
in Nebraska the flashing lights of a
state troopers Cruiser were hardly
visible as he made his way to the
vehicle after rushing into action to
help a stranded driver in Kansas City
one person died when their minivan
plunged into an icy Creek
[Music]
when rescue crews arrived they found the
vehicle turned over in the water this is
one of at least five deaths due to the
winter storm the South won't escape this
once in a generation storm either frigid
temperatures and snow is expected by
Thursday the Oklahoma Highway Patrol
reported more than 300 crashes I'm in
the door while outside Dallas Rocky
Garcia is using battery-operated lights
to keep warm on the coldest day of the
Season while power is out I'm really
glad that I have a fireplace because
otherwise I'd be freezing right now
now here in the Chicago area it is eight
below as temperatures drop across the
country cities are opening warming
centers to help people escape the
dangerous cold Gail I know man they
don't call it the windy city for nothing
thank you Elise glad you have on a hat
and a heavy coat and some gloves you
look like a snow bunny I like it